well today a group of GOP lawmakers they
held a press conference to call out the
blatant double standard within the FBI
the obvious conflicts of interest within
the Muller team take a look
each day we learn more information that
reflects the double standard that
unfortunately seems to be pervasive at
the FBI and at the Department of Justice
was this dossier discredited dossier
paid for by DNC and Clinton campaign
money was this dossier in fact used was
it part of what was taken to the FISA
Court to allow spying to take place on
Americans who were associated with the
Trump campaign if Mueller was doing such
a great job on investigating the Russian
collusion why could he have not found
the conflict of interest within their
own agency the time for action is now
and there is a short fuse on were
demanding the kind of evidence and
transparency that the American people
deserve here now live from Washington
with much more our freedom caucus
members its chairman congressman mark
meadows North Carolina Florida
congressman Matt Gaetz is with us
congressman meadows let me begin with
you and I mean there's so much to get
into yeah great point it was a Hillary
Clinton bought and paid for hillary
controlled DNC bought and paid for
propaganda dossier but did they use that
as a reason to get a warrant to surveil
against people and in either the Trump
campaign or the president-elect
well we've asked for the FISA
application document to be delivered to
Congress we think the American people
need to know but you know here's an
interesting question Sean that you and
I've been talking about this for weeks
but here we have Peter struck who
actually was leading the Clinton
investigation now the same person who
was not only interviewed interviewing
Cheryl Mills and uma Abidine but also
was the same individual who changed the
exoneration letter from extremely
grossly negligent extreme careless crime
to extreme carelessness and yet here is
the person that Bob Mueller
to be on his investigative team now
there's a real problem with that when
you know that he was involved in the
first investigation and now we're asking
him to go after Trump I can't see the
logic of it I talk congressman gates
about the weaponization of our powerful
tools of intelligence we are now looking
at a special council that has Comey and
struck and page and Weissman and all
these Democratic donors and a lot of
Trump haters and Hillary lovers and this
guy struck it's time to everything your
thoughts what do we need to do well the
Attorney General needs to do his job and
end this witch-hunt charade we have a
clear double standard and you see it and
the American people see it Hillary
Clinton's being investigated by her own
fan club before the 2016 election and
now the only way you seem to get on
Muller's team is to demonstrate a hatred
for Donald Trump I think that the way
Muller built his team was finding people
who had a bias against the president and
doing everything he could to include
that at them in this investigation and
it's absolutely ludicrous struck is a
big problem but you also have a jeanne
ray you've got Andrew McCabe telling
people that we have to treat Hillary
Clinton special I mean she's got a small
team at headquarters investigating her
meanwhile we got more people
investigating Donald Trump than
investigated the Oklahoma City bombing
for goodness so we have to considering
the fix was in mark meadows don't we now
have to have a fair if we're gonna have
equal justice under the law well we
really we really do we need to not only
have a special prosecutor maybe to
investigate the investigators and and
we're here to tell you tonight not only
do we have a task force that is being
set up under chairman Gowdy and chairman
Goodlatte that includes Jim Jordan
myself John Ratcliffe Ken Buck we're
working with Matt Gaetz and Ron DeSantis
to get to the bottom of it but the
American people have had enough you know
here's the interesting thing I've got
union workers back home in North
Carolina who paid dues many of them went
to Hillary Clinton those dues went to
Hillary Clinton who actually they ended
up buying off Russian informants in
in a choir style dossier and they were
actually voting for those exactly what
they say they don't like about Trump
that they can't prove for a year last
thing what do we do I don't even know
what to do about Robert Muller
congressman slash yeah Shawn what I
would say is first thing we need to do
is we need to get rid of this Muller
investigation and the Attorney General
Jeff Sessions sees the same things we
see so I don't know why Jeff Sessions is
not fired Bob Muller yet as a
consequence of this terrible
investigation second thing we need to do
we need to set up procedures at the FBI
where there's more oversight and
transparency so that this never happens
again so that we never get a rogue FBI
director like James Secret it determines
the outcome for this the worst you've
ever seen it absolutely this is the
worst and I tell you what the time is
now for Jeff Sessions to do his job and
if he doesn't do his job you know he
needs to step aside and let somebody
else do it
thank you both I told I totally
completely wholeheartedly agree I'm told
that it's being done there's no evidence
of it where is it